foreign
[Music]
here if you appreciate my content
consider hitting the like button it's
the only way the YouTube algorithm
notices me
if you'd like to do more to keep this
channel afloat consider donating through
the PayPal Link in the description or
checking out our patreon thanks guys so
much
part one the birth and future of
cyberpunk
the 1980s saw the birth of a new genre
of Science Fiction cyberpunk William
Gibson's Neuromancer ignited the spark
laying the foundation for a genre that
would Captivate the minds of readers at
influence countless films video games
and artworks but every Journey has its
destination and as we explore the vast
landscape of cyberpunk literature we
discover that Neil Stevens and Snow
Crash marks a crucial Turning Point the
genres Pinnacle of development and the
birth of a new element satirical
cyberpunk
Neuromancer a groundbreaking novel
introduced us to a world of hacking
virtual reality and corporate control it
ushered in an era of greedy protagonists
navigating through labyrinthine networks
confronting powerful entities and
questioning the boundaries between
humanity and machines the genre had
taken its first steps setting the tone
for what would come next over time
cyberpunk flourished and evolved weaving
its way into the collective
consciousness
a multitude of Works explored the theme
of Technology's Dark Side portraying
futuristic dystopias filled with hackers
cyborgs and mega corporations however as
the genre matured its tropes became
familiar and its themes often echoed
each other leading some to believe that
cyberpunk had exhausted its creative
potential and so as the cyberpunk
landscape reached its apex snow crash in
1992 emerged on the scene Neil
Stevenson's satirical Masterpiece
provided a refreshing twist signaling
the genre's evolution into new territory
satire with its sharp wit and Keen
observations became the tool of choice
for Stevenson to dissect and critique
the world he envisioned as we journey
alongside hero protagonist and YT we
encounter a cyberpunk setting that
deliberately exaggerates the genre's
elements creating a vibrant almost
cartoonish world that is both familiar
and absurd third and Snow Crash we
witness a society where corporate power
and virtual realities intertwine where
information becomes a weapon and
Linguistics hold Divine significance
Stevenson uses humor and irony to shine
a light on society's absurdities and the
dangers of unchecked Technology while
still paying homage to the core
cyberpunk ethos as I said the story
follows the protagonist reasonably named
hero protagonist a freelance hacker and
sword-wielding pizza delivery driver he
frequently enters into the metaverse a
vast virtual reality space in this world
a new drug called snow crash has emerged
snow crash serves as both a potent
narcotic and a computer virus that
affects hackers brains rendering them
brain dead in both the real and Virtual
Worlds Hero's friend and fellow hacker
whose name I believe is pronounced David
Falls victim to the drug and Hero
embarks on a quest to unravel the
Mysteries behind snow crash's Origins
and find a cure for the infection as he
investigates Hiro discovers a deeper
conspiracy involving an ancient language
the Sumerian language which has the
ability to reprogram human Minds when
encountered in the digital realm we will
talk more about this in just a moment
snow crash is referred to in the novel
as a metavirus
bad news a metavirus Juanita said it's
the atomic bomb of informational Warfare
a virus that causes any systems to
infect itself with new viruses hero
teams up with YT a young and resourceful
skateboard Courier and they uncover a
plot that involves snow crash being
released onto the world as a tool of
control and domination the Duo's Journey
takes them through a chaotic landscape
of corporate controlled enclaves and
Refugee filled residential
semi-sovereign gated communities called
burb claves along the way they encounter
a diverse cast including a religious and
highly skilled hacker named Juanita
Marquez as hero and YT delve deeper into
the conspiracy they must confront
formidable enemies and overcome both
virtual and real world challenges the
story combines action-packed sequences
with thought-provoking explorations of
Technology Linguistics and the potential
consequences of unchecked corporate
power all I might add with a satirical
Edge throughout snow crash Neil
Stevenson weaves elements of satire and
humor using the cyberpunk genres tropes
to satirize contemporary society and its
relationship to technology the success
of snow crash as a parody stems from its
genuine appreciation for the genre it
gently mocks while some parodies may be
dismissive or cynical Stevenson's work
Embraces cyberpunk's Legacy celebrating
its influence while pushing its
boundaries snow crash was a breath of
fresh air for cyberpunk it demonstrated
that the genre could adapt and evolve
while maintaining its relevance and
Allure Stevenson satire not only
entertained readers but also forced us
to reflect on our own relationship with
technology and like I said the potential
consequences of its unchecked growth
all of that being said I found one
element in snow crash to be far more
entertaining than the rest in my opinion
the most interesting Concept in snow
crash which I actually made this entire
video to discuss is the concept of the
proto-human language
part two the proto-human language
Neil Stevenson didn't invent the concept
of the proto-human language but he makes
interesting usage of it in this book
this idea has existed for thousands of
years but the proto-human language is a
concept that was first speculated on in
a serious capacity by Italian linguist
Alfredo trombetti he advocated for the
doctrine of monogenesis which suggested
that all living humans descended from a
single pair of ancestors but he took
this a step further saying that not only
had humans originated from a common
ancestral pair but that all human
languages spoken by humans currently on
Earth could be traced back to a single
common language a mother language that
would have given birth to all other
tongues in 1905 he released the unit of
origin of the language a Doctrine which
till this day remains controversial in
it he estimates that the common ancestor
of existing languages had been spoken
between one thousand to two thousand
centuries ago this idea it was widely
dismissed in the late 1800s and the
early 1900s as the idea of polygenesis
was extremely popular polygenesis
postulated that the different races of
Earth Had Each originated from unrelated
groups essentially the opposite of
monogenesis by the mid-20th century the
best known supporter of linguistic
monogenesis in the United States was a
man by the name of Morris swatish he
actually pioneered a method of
comparative linguistics called
lexicostatistics there was also Joseph
Greenberg an American linguist who
created large-scale classifications of
the world's languages he never
explicitly endorsed the concept of
monogenesis but his work was highly
suggestive of it monogenesis and the
genetic sense is accepted in modern
anthropology but the proto-human
language remains uncertain and subject
to debate
now some researchers think that real
language began after a long period of
basic human communication this happened
around 50 000 years ago during a period
called the middle and upper Paleolithic
consequently researcher Richard Klein
postulated that the capacity for complex
speech evolved among humans some 50 000
years ago coinciding with the appearance
of modern humans or cro-magnons on the
contrary Johanna Nichols in her work
argued that the diversification of vocal
languages within our species likely
commenced at least one hundred thousand
years ago in 2001 an article in the
academic Journal Science magazine
proposed an African origin for modern
human languages the proposition posited
that human language predates Out of
Africa migrations which occurred some
fifty thousand to seventy thousand years
ago and further suggested that language
might have constituted a pivotal
cultural and cognitive Innovation that
facilitated human colonization across
the globe basically this means that the
development of language was a
prerequisite to human colonization of
the globe in 2012 a study called dating
the origin of language using phenomic
diversity by anthropologists and
archaeologist Charles purelt an
anthropologist Sarah Matthew it is
estimated that the time of the first
emergence of human language was
predicted on the phonemic diversity a
phoneme is basically any perceptually
distinct units of sound in a specified
language that distinguish one word from
another for example SBD and T in the
English words sad sat bad and bad their
estimation was based on the premise that
phonemic diversity evolves at a
considerably slower Pace than grammar or
vocabulary progressively increasing over
time while diminishing among small
founding populations the largest phoneme
inventories were found in African
languages while the smallest were found
in South America and Oceania regions
that were among the last to be colonized
the authors utilized data from the
colonization of Southeast Asia to gauge
the rate of increase in diversity by
applying this rate to African languages
they determine that the estimated age of
the first human language was in between
000 and 350 000 years ago which aligns
with the emergence of the early
dispersal of homo sapiens however some
critics have contested the validity of
this approach citing potential flaws in
its methodology Lyle Richard Campbell
who is known for his study of indigenous
American languages points out that many
established proto- languages lack an
equivalent word for certain human body
parts due to the frequent replacement of
taboo words in the Lexicon he argues
that it is highly unlikely for a
proto-world form of such a word to
survive across numerous languages
Campbell emphasizes that considering the
extensive time elapsed since the origin
of human language every word from that
era would have undergone replacement or
alteration beyond recognition in
present-day languages Campbell strongly
criticizes attempts to reconstruct a
proto-human language he says that it is
at best a feudal waste of time and at
worst an embarrassment to the field of
linguistics he warns that such Endeavors
could mislead those seeking to
understand in this domain
so essentially we don't know if the
proto-human language was a real thing
some say there is evidence many say it
is merely a fiction but that is okay
because fiction is why we are here now
let's take a look at how Neil Stevenson
utilizes this concept in his book
part three the language virus
in the novel Snow Crash by Neil
Stevenson the snow Crush virus is a
highly dangerous and sophisticated
computer virus that ultimately turns out
to be far more than just a piece of
malicious software it is both a
biological virus and a computer virus
capable of infecting both human minds
and computer systems simultaneously
the name snow crash is derived from its
unique mode of attack wherein victims
experience a visual and auditory
hallucination resembling static or white
noise similar to the appearance of snow
on an old analog TV in the novel's
narrative snow crash is developed as a
powerful tool by L Bob Rife a wealthy
and ruthless media Mogul who owns a vast
conglomerate of media and communication
Enterprises Rife intends to use the
virus to control and manipulate people's
minds through the delivery of
information encoded in the snow crash
data stream those who are exposed to the
virus suffer from the loss of higher
cognitive functions becoming docile and
easily controllable the virus is
directly related to the concept of Babel
which refers to the biblical story of
the Tower of Babel of course in this
story people tried to build a tower that
would reach the heavens and as a
punishment for their arrogance God
confused their language causing them to
speak different tongues and no longer
understand each other and the whole of
Earth was of one language and of one
speech and it came to pass as they
journeyed from the East that they found
a plane in the land of shinar and they
dwelt there and they said to one another
come let us make bricks and burn them
thoroughly and they had brick for stone
and slime they had for Mortar and they
said come let us build us a city and a
tower whose top May reach unto heaven
and let us make us a name lest we be
scattered abroad upon the face of the
whole Earth
and the Lord came down to see the city
and the tower which the children of men
built and the Lord said behold the are
one and they have all one language and
this they begin to do and now nothing
will be withheld from them which they
have imagined to do come let us go down
and there confound their language that
they may not understand one another's
speech so the Lord scattered them abroad
from Vince upon the face of all the
Earth and they left off building the
city therefore is the name of it called
Babel that is confusion because the Lord
did there confound the language of all
the Earth and from thence did the Lord
scatter them abroad upon the face of all
the Earth Genesis 11 verses 1-9
Stevenson draws a parallel between the
snow crash virus and the Tower of
Babel's story because they both contain
an element showing how language can be
manipulated to effect and control human
behavior in the novel Stevenson weaves
in elements related to the proto-human
language hypothesis and monogenesis
through use of the ancient Sumerian
language
in the story of the Sumerian language is
depicted as having a unique property
that allows it to directly interface
with the human brain this suggests that
the Sumerian language might be a
candidate for a hypothetical
proto-language that could be the origin
of all human languages in reality
Sumerian is the oldest written language
that we have located and Sumer is the
earliest known civilization in the
region of southern Mesopotamia existing
between 5500 BC to 1475 BC in the novel
the virus snow crash exploits a
linguistic feature of Sumerian to
manipulate and control human Minds which
implies a strong connection between the
language and human behavior this also
brushes on the topic of Wharf hypothesis
a principle suggesting that the
structure of a language influences its
speaker's worldview or cognition and
thus individuals languages determine or
shape their perceptions of the world
the novel's portrayal of the Sumerian
language as a powerful tool that
influences the human brain aligns with
the idea that a common proto-language
could have held significant influence
over early human cognition and behavior
by incorporating the concept of a
powerful metavirus hidden within
Sumerian the novel explores the
intriguing idea that language itself
could have been a fundamental Force
shaping human evolution and development
this notion resonates with the broader
linguistic hypothesis a proto-human
language and monogenesis which seek to
understand the origins and
diversification of human languages from
a common linguistic ancestor
I find these Concepts extremely
fascinating though snow crash is clearly
satirical these ideas are compelling
furthermore many ideas and Concepts in
it have heavily influenced our culture
and the development of Technology
part 4 the legacy of snow crash Neil
Stevenson snow crash has undeniably left
a powerful cultural Legacy since its
publication in 1992. as a seminal work
in the cyberpunk genre the novel revived
interest in futuristic dystopian
settings virtual reality and the fusion
of Technology with human consciousness
the concept of the metaverse introduced
in the book had a profound influence on
how virtual reality and online gaming
have been perceived and developed in the
real world moreover snow crash
popularized various terms and Concepts
that have become ingrained in Internet
culture and hacker communities
perpetuating its impact on contemporary
language and communication
Beyond its technological influence
the novel's thought-provoking
exploration of language and cognition
particularly through the fictionalized
version of the Sumerian language has
sparked discussions on the origins and
the evolution of human languages while
the Sumerian aspects of the story are of
course speculative fiction it has opened
up doors for engaging conversations
about the possible connections between
language and human behavior furthermore
the novel's social commentary on
corporate control media manipulation and
the implications of unchecked capitalism
has stood the test of time this is a
theme that snow crash and other works
like it borrow from Neuromancer by
William Gibson and also like Neuromancer
it serves as a cautionary tale prompting
readers to contemplate the delicate
balance between advancing technology and
preserving individual freedoms and
privacy in essence Neil Stevenson snow
crash has transcended its status as a
novel and become a cultural Touchstone
influencing the way we perceive
technology and language and Society by
blending thrilling cyberpunk elements
with insightful socio-political
commentary and satire Stevenson crafted
a work that continues to resonate with
audiences and shape the way we interact
with the ever-evolving technological
landscape
conclusion
the route snow crash Neil Stevenson
masterfully weaves elements of satire
and humor using the cyberpunk genres
tropes to satirize contemporary society
and its relationship with technology the
novel is a wild and imaginative ride
blending cyberpunk Aesthetics with
linguistic historical and philosophical
themes making it a highly influential
and Unforgettable work in the cyberpunk
literary canon the success of snow crash
as a parody stems from its genuine
appreciation for the genre it gently
mocks while some parodies might be
dismissive or cynical Stevenson's work
Embraces cyberpunk's Legacy celebrating
its influence while pushing its
boundaries
snow crash is a fantastic read I had a
lot of fun with it and if you are
interested in exploring Neil Stevens's
answer to the first 10 years of the
cyberpunk genre it's a great book to
check out
and now we'll be moving on to patreon
questions as always if you want to
support this channel you can check out
the patreon link in the description or
donate through PayPal
the first question comes from Jonathan
Robertson
you are one of the most astute observers
and Scholars of Science Fiction I have
come across on YouTube did you find
yourself in this wonderful world on your
own or did someone inspire you my late
father got me into literary science
fiction and I am not sure if I would
have gravitated towards it without his
guidance did you have a mentor or
someone who urged you into this field if
so thank them if not give yourself a pat
on the back your videos have been a
blessing
well I didn't so much have really a
mentor that put me on to liking science
fiction it was something that I just it
was something that I really just
stumbled upon I always read a lot of
books as a kid and it was really my
escape from the kind of tumultuous
environment that I was growing up in now
I will say that my grandfather was a big
fan of Stephen King movies he wasn't
really a reader but I would always watch
Stephen King movies with him so by the
time I became a teenager and I started
reading Stephen King books I was already
primed to that kind of weirdness and
then Stephen King led me into other
things like Lovecraft and and then from
there I branched off into all sorts of
different things so I feel like my real
big science fiction boom kind of
happened in High School whereas before
that I was reading a lot of books and
some of them might have been science
fiction but I wasn't really thinking
about it in terms of this is fantasy
this is science fiction I was just kind
of enjoying the stories thank you for
your question and thank you for your
compliments as well
so our next question is from Donovan
Carr I recently went back and watched
some of your older videos in particular
those that mention Abomination and
Aaliyah if the female Benny Jesuit can
only access the genetic memories of
female ancestors after successfully
taking the Water of Life then how can
Aaliyah be possessed by Vladimir
harkonen I wouldn't have thought that
the male side of the memories could be
accessed well Donovan Carr that's a very
good question and that is a question
that a lot of people have asked and I
tend to agree with comic book girl 19's
interpretation of this and if you have
not watched Danica's Dune Club I
definitely highly recommend it so
essentially what's going on here is that
the Benny Jesuit women have access to
the female half of their genetic
ancestry so not just the female Memories
the female half of the genetic ancestry
so all the memories on the female's side
you get what I'm saying so she has the
memories of all of Jessica's ancestors
because ultimately it doesn't make sense
if she only had access to female
ancestors but if you consider it with
this interpretation it all comes into
place I totally get why this is a little
confusing but I think that this is
probably the proper interpretation
the next question comes from James
Donahoe what are your opinions on the
recently released Uzumaki anime clip do
you think this adaptation will do
justice to the manga so Uzumaki is a
fantastic story written by junji Ito
it's very lovecraftian and weird I
highly recommend it it's about the
strange events that occur in this like
little Japanese town
and recently a clip from the show has
been released I'm definitely excited I'm
definitely going to give it a try I'm
going to watch it around Halloween time
hopefully and I think it looks like this
could be a fun way to re-experience that
story and I'm excited for it personally
my next question comes from Rob love
have you ever thought to yourself when
reading a novel man I wish I could be
alive in this fictional world slash
universe if so which one and why well
some people are gonna think this answer
is a cop-out but the answer is anytime I
read like a novelized episode of Star
Trek or something the Star Trek universe
is just so compelling to me and anytime
I watch a Next Generation or I'm
immersing myself in one of those stories
in book form
I just am teleported and I wish that I
lived on the Enterprise I just wish I
lived in in an era of humanity where we
had moved past scarcity and that we had
moved past like our problems as humans
and that we were exploring the cosmos
and that we were
um exploring strange new worlds I just
adored the Star Trek universe it's so
comfortable to me it's so like nostalgic
to me I just really really love Star
Trek and I'm exposing myself now I'm
really I've really just been a Star Trek
fanatic this whole time
thank you for your question Rob love now
our final patreon question for today
comes from Joseph what do you think will
be the next major theme in future
science fiction novels well science
fiction often recycles and reimagines
ideas but I think in the next 20 30 50
years we're going to see a lot of
obviously AI stuff but what I really
think is going to make a huge boom in
the next 50 30 years as far as science
fiction is concerned is transhumanism
and of course science fiction authors
I've been talking about transhumanism
for a long time but I really expect it
to ramp up as transhumanism becomes more
and more of a real thing as we alter our
minds and bodies more and more with
technology and augment ourselves it's
going to raise questions about what it
even means to be human how many parts
can you replace before you're actually
something different entirely what
fundamentally makes us human is it our
DNA is it our specific brand of
Consciousness what grouping of features
supports the emerging property of
humanity key within us
what is it and how many of those
features can we alter and remove and
still maintain that Humanity so I think
that's a question that's going to be in
a lot more science fiction as we go
forward and then like I mentioned AI as
AI begins to take over and integrate
more and more with us and the way we
operate every day
we truly are at a point in time in which
the prospect of Technology integrating
with humankind in like a more physical
way is becoming more and more obvious
microchips inside of bodies uh body
parts that are entirely mechanical it's
happening and it's only going to
increase
and I also think that what is so cool
about science fiction is that it kind of
mentally prepares you for these Concepts
and ideas it kind of shows you the
possible Futures and prepares you for
what is potentially to come reading a
bunch of science fiction books is kind
of like being the quiz that's how to
Rack a little bit you can gaze into the
possible futures of humanity and kind of
like see where we maybe could go if
certain things happen so thank you guys
so much for watching as I said you can
check out our patreon if you would like
to support this Channel or use the
PayPal Link in the description thanks
guys
and don't forget to check out my brand
new podcast the cosmic Chronicles
podcast I've been having a lot of fun
with my co-host James talking about
various sci-fi ideas and books and
movies that I love and enjoy check it
out Link in the description
foreign
[Music]